welcome everybody this is our second
webinar for our cloud products and today
we'll be talking about using bigquery to
explore in search sorry metadata that
we've made available before we can get
started with the actual presentation I
would like you to take poll for us about
your familiarity with
isequal and bigquery you can just click
on your screen to answer the question
and once we get some responses I'll
close it and share this with everybody
and this kind of helps me to tailor the
webinar to your needs so that I can go
into more detail about certain things or
in less detail if it's not needed so it
looks like most of you have heard of
sequel but haven't actually used it so
we have another quote for if you've used
bigquery besides just helping tailor
this to the mobile more it also helps us
to understand your use cases and the
products were building for you meet your
needs
okay so it looks like most of you have
heard or and use the query and for some
of you this is the first experience
you'll be having with it so I'm glad to
be able to explain it so no quick
introduction for our agenda so I'll go
through a story in the cloud and what
bigquery is and after that short
introduction also straight into the
actual demo of the three use cases we'll
be presenting today so we're in the
cloud what is it at this point we've
moved all of our data to the clouds and
we have deposited more than 12 terabytes
of data into the cloud and this number
grows daily but having all that either
it doesn't actually help anybody sense
you need a good way of actually
searching for the right data sets that
you want to compute on and this is where
the query comes and this is our first
negative product
or doing search for datasets and it has
two major benefits one is it starts
response to the queries you will run and
the multiple methods you can use to
access it it has a web interface it has
a command line API it has multiple
libraries that you can use in your
programming languages like Python and
also Gangstar sequel it is fairly easy
there is only a couple of concepts you
need to understand before you can dive
in and start exploring it so if you are
interested to learn more about sequel
google has made a lot of efforts to
provide documentation for bigquery they
have three syntax explanations they have
tutorials
they have how-to documents besides what
Google provides there are online
tutorials or and web classes you can
sign up for some of them are free some
of them are paid where you can learn
sequel as well you can also search
forums for questions on how to write
queries one of the popular ones its
Stack Overflow
where you can submit a question and
people will help you answer it but
there's also lots of lots of questions
being asked already so you can certainly
reuse those answers that's provided so
bigquery is just a giant data warehouse
and we've deposited two days let's enter
it the first is the assert metadata
which includes several information have
a sample sequence and some basic
statistics on the run sequencing run
that was performed the second day is
that that we have is the sra taxonomic
content analysis this analysis is done
using a k-mer approach and we predict
species that within particular run based
on these unique angers and you can take
both there's also for these their sites
combine them in a query and this will
help you have a more filtered result
depending on your use case
so a quick overview about sequel so
there's a select statement that tells
that we're going to be extracting data
from tables
there's the throne clause that won't
tell the database from what tables we're
going to be extracting data from there's
the where clause that specifies the
filters were applying to those tables
and common want to use his order by
which helps to order the data set based
on particular column something maybe
like release date or accession numbers
there's other operators used in sequel
some of these are like the equal sign
others that you'll see my queries are
the in operator which you can use to
provide them this to a particular column
there's the unless operator that helps
you flatten an array into its own table
and there's the like operator which
allows you to do patent searches so
you'll see those in my use cases so we
have three use cases that we're gonna
demo one is finding the taxonomic
distribution of human gut and other
genomes the second one is finding Kona
verde data within SRA and the third one
is identifying bronze for earth OPS's
gene expression studies this point I'll
just jump straight into the actual demo
so here we have my first query which is
the finding tectonic content human gut
meta-genome so I'm just not writing it
now because it takes about 30 seconds to
run but to go over the syntax here so
I'm selecting only three columns
I'm selecting the accession column the
name column and a column called self
count self count column represents the
number of chamber hits now in the from
clause I have two tables one is the
serie metadata
where I'm providing the alias for M and
I have the SRA tools tax analysis table
and the areas for that is cats so the
others just make it easier to write
queries where you don't need to rewrite
to the entire table name every single
time I'm then joining the two tables
based on the accession columns I'm
providing a list of organisms to search
in the metadata table for the organism
column and I'm looking for only public
datasets these days that's publicly
available and do not require any
permissions to access bigquery does have
even gap data and so in order to make
sure I don't need to apply for special
access for future studies I'm just
looking for offered at ax and then I'm
filtering that economic results provide
me only the results for the species that
they found my analysis table contains
the entire examine tree for particular
species that was identified and if
you're interested in seeing the whole
tree you can certainly build that out
right for this example I just want the
actual species living in the human death
and the genome so a couple things you
can pay attention to on the web
interface is they give you identify how
much data will be processed with a query
very easily here on the right hand side
and they provides a quick check that
there are no syntax errors in your query
services kind of a quick check you can
do by eye to make sure that your query
is fine so now that we have our results
we have our accessions tell them the
name for the species that are within the
succession session and the number of
camera hits so looking at this we can
also see that this result came back with
the roughly 40 million rows so this is a
lot of data here and you can quickly
scan through by eye if you want but
there's no way to scan through 40
million rows so of course the next that
might be how do you visualize something
like this what do you do once you have
this how to visualize the camera it's in
easy-to-understand manner and there's a
couple ways you can do this the first
step though would be to actually save
these results so you somewhere
unfortunately Google does provide
certain limits to what you can save your
file
directly from running a query so in this
case there's a 1 gigabyte limit or if
you're saving to a local file it only
will save 16,000 rows however there is
an option to save the result as its own
bigquery table and this is what you will
actually need to do once you save the
result is a big great table then you
have a couple different options which
you can do you can then send that entire
table to Google's data studio and use
that to visualize the data build some
graphs and dashboards for the data or if
you want to run your own statistical
analysis on the data you can save export
the entire table as a file now this is
why you need to save the result as a
table so that you can send an expert
command either through the web interface
command line or through one of those
libraries I mentioned for programming
language to export the entire table into
a file into a Google bucket now once the
expert is finished you have a file that
you can work on however if you do want
to get that file to your local computer
you will need to pay egress charges to
download that data from your Google
bucket into your local computer so
depending on your use case and where you
want to perform your analysis those are
some of the different options available
for you to work with such a large data
set as this error this can provide you
some input about what species live in
even got metagenomes so I think this is
really useful so now we'll move forward
to our second use case and you can see
that I saved all my use cases as queries
and which is very easy to do you can
just click save query and save as and
then just provide anything you want to
it so for our second use case which is
planning car and leveraging data set I
can just that and grai and run it very
quickly so this is a much smaller yet
that better query answer it'll come back
it's a little faster so in this case
what I'm looking for is the bio project
the biosample expressions the wrong
session the collection date the general
location of where the sample was
collected who it was collected by and
the host of the sample and just like
last time on querying the metadata
people and its economy analysis table
when I'm searching for in this case is
the curve that varied a family so
instead of looking for particular
species or all species I'm flying it a
particular family that I'm looking for
and as you can see we have lots of good
metadata like a new scalp or purse
examples where we have a collection date
the location who is collected by and
others but as you can see there are some
datasets that don't have a lot of
metadata and this is one of their
challenges with working with user
submitted data is that they you would
expect to be there might not be there
because there was never actually
submitted to NCBI you or in this case to
be bi since this is an our DNA accession
power you can use the assets to identify
runs going to be useful for you
or downstream analysis so in case if you
are interested in human based boosts you
can certainly then pull out the Asura
accessions save those to a file and feed
those accessions to the SRA toolkit to
dump ASCII files or Sam files and then
run your own computational tools on
those festive events and files it makes
things easier within the grade Vickery
provides a lot of useful tools and
shortcuts one of these is they provide
an autocomplete feature so to just
quickly down with that it would be if I
started writing something in this case I
want to maybe filter the data set based
on when the datasets were released
so I'm gonna search the meditator table
and then I just hit pad and then I can
see all the columns within the metadata
the table and then if I just started
typing what I want which is the release
date it will auto complete and select
the date for me so in this case I can
quickly find a column that I want using
this other complete feature and if you
want to learn more about shortcuts
Vickery does have this little short
right a tool that you can move through
and see the different shortcuts
available for you in this case if I
wanted to talk there buying at least
eight I can say I want all the samples
that were released within this year and
so it makes it very easy to write your
queries using this autocomplete feature
so you don't have to memorize all the
columns available in all of our tables
so moving to words our last example here
which is finding her though this
they set for artistic analysis so in
this case this query is a little bit
more complicated because I'm working
with a lot more metadata submitted by
users so in this case what I'm doing is
I'm opening the attributes column within
the metadata table and this attribute
column is an array so I use the unlist
operator to make it a flat table and
then I'm looking for all the keys with
the name of tissue organism part or
organism sample and I'm providing that
an alias called tissue so this way I can
quickly identify with the tissue boards
for the data set
next I'm looking for what the treatment
was for this data set I basically copy
and pasted the above query and change
the keys to treatment environment stress
condition for this sample now you might
ask how do I know what keys to use in
this array column well that was more
complicated step where I move through
different examples of different samples
and I think this these out and seeing
them as a list to be used in this query
so there will be some work trying to
identify the correct keys to use because
different submitters like to provide
different attribute names when they're
submitting their data so it makes it
hard to standardize searches like this
so besides that I'm also going to pull
out all of them in the data columns but
I'm providing it the except operator
here because I don't want these five
columns to be displayed so instead of
typing out metadata accession and essay
type and all the other type columns I
want to display it's quicker to provide
a list of
I don't want to display for the throne
cause I'm providing it the melody table
with an alias and what else I'm doing is
I'm going to underst
again the attribute columns as its own
table the query will join these two
tables on the back end by itself you
don't have to worry about that and the
filters are applying here is the actual
organism name and I'm going to search
through the sample attributes looking
for the keyword either leave route or
leaves and then the other approach it is
vanity that has this column called
j8 8 year owner and this is the JSON
attributes column where we took all via
simple attributes and provide them as
JSON so here I'm searching based on a
pattern before the word drought now the
% replies that it will apply one or more
characters before or after the word
drought so I'm doing a very broad search
here and to make sure that I'm pulling
out the gene expression once I provide
the library source as transcriptomic you
can also take a look at the s8 like here
is also set to par and they see that
could actually be another filter you
apply so looking at the results we have
roughly 300 data sets where the tissue
was a type of leaf or wood with a
treatment relating to drought so having
looked at this and maybe pull out some
other attributes to filter the data set
maybe by sequencing platform how what
minor selection strategy was used I can
narrow the data set even further I don't
have they go the idea is you pull out
the wrong expressions and get the actual
data to run some mathematics RDC
computation on
so those are the three these cases I
wanted to provide to you go through the
queries I'm using and potential use of
the results now waiting the query is not
free but it is very very cheap so
careful I just a quick predicted cost
for running these queries as you can see
the biggest one was the human gut
meta-genome where we extracted 40
million rooms but that only cost us
roughly 40 cents the gorillas very
dataset was significant smaller than
just 30 cents and there paradoxus
example it was only 10 cents so getting
started with bigquery it's very cheap as
well so we are always looking for
feedback the only way we know how to
improve our tools and what we're doing
is if the community speaks to us so if
you have suggestions for improvements
please don't have to take the contact
size just right to suggest that NCBI and
provide us any feedback that you wish
about I think we're doing well or things
that we can improve to fit your use
cases the more we hear from you better
we can provide the tools that you need
for new research and here are some
general URLs that you can look for more
information so we have more
documentation available about bigquery
and access than they are in the clouds
at array if you want to learn more about
how to export large days that Google
does provide the directions for that if
you want to play around with data studio
there is not meditation available and
please sign up for our YouTube channel
as we hold more webinars and provide
more instructional videos or others
videos will be available there so it's a
good resource to have for you and that's
about it thank you thank you so we have
a few questions in the quest
spod there's been some questions about
costs and you did a good job of
explaining what those particular queries
cost but there is a free tour tear is
there not for Google you could you run
any of these queries on the free tier
yes let's provide I have a free tier
approach where the number of queries you
can one is limited but you can certainly
do that and if you sign up for bigquery
with yourself Google so provides you one
terabyte of data to process free every
single month so it's possible to sign up
and some limit for yourself how much
data you want to process and just stay
within that one terabyte free limit
which I think might be a little bit
higher than the free tier but that part
I'm not quite sure about but there
certainly is a free tier for Victoria
okay another question actually there's a
couple of related questions it has to do
with and there will you know the columns
and sort of keys that you cert are and I
think it's not the rabbit docks a rabbit
out for this example so one question is
what happens if there is multiple key
matches what results do you get back so
for example being the information about
treatment could be in three possible
keys I think right it's really possible
in this case there wasn't any overlap
between these three keys pretty possible
that there could be yeah potentially
that could be so I would actually need
to explore that exactly how this
particular query would act that way I
think which is the general question too
as well as how it would behave if that
was the case yes this is the
complication with having user submitted
meta data where the keys can change and
difference the members will use
different keys to mean the same thing so
you need to be very careful
you used those keys and we might
potentially run into an error regarding
the result depending on how the query
structured so it does take some playing
around with the query to get the exact
result that she wants he thinks he
related to that is this concept of the
user submitted data having some lack of
control I guess is maybe one way of
putting it and someone wanted to know if
we had if NCBI had done any work that
sort of group related columns so that it
would be easier to people to make for
people to make precise queries right so
NCBI does try to standardize the
metadata that will request from people
during submission time that certainly
helps we have not had the chance to do
more work on standardizing that metadata
when it's only is something that we're
aware of that needs to happen and we'll
be working on it in the future to make
this process easier when writing queries
but this time we haven't dug too deep
into it simply because of the complexity
of the task but it's certainly something
on our roadmap to do okay thanks Siri
another question is about you know is
there a way to run a query suppose you
run a query today and then you want to
run a query say a month later but you
don't want to you want to only query the
the new data the stuff that's come in
and in the past month just you know save
some money basically these are way to do
that not not yet as far as
understandable how the query works it
searches the entire data set for for
your results you can certainly set
limits that's what set filters for when
the data been submitted or released and
so your return would be smaller you have
a query will still search the entire
data set oh I see so that would be
applied after the
after the search yeah okay another
question just to be with sort of
diagramming the database a bank is is
there a UML or an ER model of esra
cables so we provide the schemas in our
documentation available at SRA so if we
go to the Australian landing page we
have s around the cloud here and within
the search big query of pages we have
links to the actual tables and some
explanations on what columns can be used
we did not be together a full your model
diagram but you can also link our entire
project in the query web interface if
you go to print project here and you
would need to type in NIH - a survey -
dare store and click pin and then you
would be able to take a look at what is
available for sale within bigquery so
here you can take a look at the tables
and see what columns and types are
available for all of these data tables
from within the query but that's a good
idea to build the UML diagrams
okay thanks URI there's another question
that I think you may have address a
little bit in the last webinar somebody
is asking if we have a pipeline
available that they can submit data
within it looks like they're trying to
filter out contamination errors from the
data I don't quite understand the
question here pipeline to submit data
the metadata yeah I'm not sure I think
they're asking about content
contamination the data they want to try
to filter out I'm not sure what kind of
contamination may be human sequences in
the genome data or stuff like something
like that
okay so we do have a process for
filtering out human data from data sets
and when the data set is submitted to
NCBI if the submitter contacts sra and
tells us they want to perform human
filtering on their days that we can
activate that process we have not built
that into our submission interfaces yet
to allow the user submitter to do that
themselves but we can certainly do that
and we have a process for that we are
working on a publication for that
process at this moment and once the
publication is made will definitely be
linking it to all the web pages ok great
Yuri that's that's I think that's very
helpful
I think we've addressed I think we've
addressed all the questions really
thanks everybody for coming thanks very
much Yuri and i think a more gentle
rules I will go ahead and end the
webinar